this is one of the most interesting
videos based on classification of
rational numbers we note that they are
either terminating decimals or non
terminating recurring decimal numbers we
also know that they can be expressed as
P divided by Q where Q is not equal to
zero but just by looking at a fraction
can you tell if it's dominating or non
terminating recurring let's see we look
at 6 rational numbers in the P by Q form
5 by 2 17 by 5 8 by 15 9 by 2017 by 6 11
by 21 without calculating the value of
each in decimal form can you directly
tell the category each of them falls
into this category or this one let's
make three rows and analyze it let this
be the row of our numbers just for our
understanding let us calculate the
decimal values of each in this row and
we read the form of each decimal in this
row by form I mean either this or this
we will write T if it's terminating and
NTR if it's non terminating recurring
let's try calculating the decimal values
of each of the numbers first 5 by 2 can
be written as 2 point 5 so we can say
that it is terminating the digits after
the decimal point end and do not go on
forever 17 by 5 equals 3 point 4 which
is also terminating 8 by 15 equals 0
point 5 3 3 3 3 and so on it does not
terminate the digit 3 is repeated
indefinitely so we can say that it is a
non terminating recurring decimal 9 by
20 equals 0.45 which is terminating so
what we are doing here is calculating
the decimal value of all the numbers and
classifying it into terminating and non
terminating recurring decimals only two
more numbers remain 17 by 6 equals 2.8
three three three and so on so correct
it gets classified as non terminating
recurring fraction and 11 by 21 equals
zero point five two three eight zero
nine five two three eight zero nine and
so on this part is repeated so it's a
non terminating recurring fraction
imagine trying to do all of this without
a calculator that's how your eyes would
look stunned don't worry there's a
quicker way all we need to do is look at
the denominator yes even if we just look
at the denominator we can figure out if
it's a terminating or non terminating
recurring the denominator of the first
number is two and the denominator of the
second number is five we just need to
keep a small thing in mind we reduce the
denominators to its prime factors the
denominator of the third number is
fifteen in terms of its prime factors it
can be written as three times five
what about twenty it can be written as
two squared multiplied by five six can
be written as 2 times 3 and 21 can be
written as three times seven
that's all we had to do reduce the
denominators to its prime factors let's
observe the denominators of the
terminating decimals the prime factors
of the denominator are either two or
five or both two and five now let's look
at the prime factors of the denominators
of nonterminating recurring decimals
they have numbers other than two and
five yes that's the trick if the prime
factors of the denominator are two or
five or both then the decimal is
terminating if the denominator contains
any prime factor other than two or five
then it's a non terminating recurring
decimal these are the only two rules you
need to remember have you noticed how
simple it is to know if the decimal is
terminating or non terminating recurring
all we have to do is write the
denominators in terms of its prime
factors and
these rules let's generalize these two
rules if the number is in the form P by
Q then all we need to do is reduce Q to
its prime factors for terminating
decimals q will be of the form 2 raise
to M multiplied by 5 raised to n where m
and n are integers it simply means that
the prime factors will be either 2 or 5
or both
and how do we generalize Q for non
terminating recurring decimals it's
simple we write it as 2 raise to M
multiplied by 5 raised to n multiplied
by K where K is a prime factor other
than 2 or 5 and M and n are integers it
can be 3 it can be 7 or 11 whatever if
the denominator contains any prime
factor other than 2 or 5 it will be a
non terminating recurring decimal
you